bitte nehmen sie platz der fängt vor
eintritt in die tagesordnung
gratuliere ich nachträglich dem kollegen
klaus peter willsch zu seinem
sechzigsten geburtstag im namen des
ganzen hauses wird sich alles gute
sie haben für den ausgeschiedenen
kollegen michael leutert ist der kollege
dr axel troost als mitglied des
bundestags nachgerückt ich begrüße sie
im namen des ganzen hauses wünsche gute
zusammenarbeit werde ihnen leicht fallen
sind sie nicht ganz neu im deutschen
bundestag
auf verlangen der fraktionen der cdu/csu
und spd findet heute nach den ohne
debatte punkten eine aktuelle stunde mit
dem titel weitere eskalation der gewalt
in myanmar stoppen und demokratische
rechte wiederherstellen stadt die vor
der fraktion bündnis 90/die grünen
verlangt der aktuelle stunde zum thema
vertrauensverlust von demokratischen
institutionen gegen drehen transparenz
von politischen entscheidungen stärken
wird morgen im anschluss einen
tagesordnungspunkt 32 aufgerufen
tagesordnungspunkt 8 d wird abgesetzt
jetzt hoffe ich auf die
tagesordnungspunkte 8a bis 18 sowie
zusatzpunkt drei beratung mehrere
vorlagen zur fortgeltung der die
epidemische lage von nationaler
tragweite betreffenden regelungen zu den
gesetzentwurf der fraktionen der cdu/csu
liegen und spd liegen ein
änderungsantrag der fraktionen der fdp
ein entschließungsantrag der fraktionen
die linke oder ein entschließungsantrag
der fraktion bündnis 90/die grünen vor
über den gesetzentwurf der fraktionen
der cdu/csu und spd werden wir später
namentlich abstimmen
für die aussprache wurde eine dauer von
60 minuten geschlossen
und diese aussprache eröffnet hier mit
und datei das wort den kollegen rudolf
henke cdu csu und komplexes
gesetzgebungsverfahren der präsident
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen meine
damen und herren liebe zuschauern um
zuschauer
die medizin ist eine soziale
wissenschaft und politik ist nichts
anderes als medizin im großen einsatz
von mir kein satz den durch zitieren
könnte es ist der satz von rudolf
virchow der hier in berlin direktor der
pathologie an der charité war der
gleichzeitig mitglied des berliner
abgeordnetenhauses des preußischen
landtags und des reichstags über
jahrzehnte gewesen ist und der ein
verständnis des verhältnisses von
wissenschaft in der medizin und politik
geprägt hat wie wir es heute anwenden
können und müssen in einem maß wie es
viele von uns sich nie hätte träumen
lassen
glaube dass unsere aufgaben die wir
fördern und voranbringen müssen darin
bestehen die weitere reduktion von
neuinfektionen in unserem land
voranzubringen
die unterbrechung der diffusen
zirkulation von saas kreft 2 in der
bevölkerung zu betreiben
eine vermeidung eines wiedereinstiegs
der fallzahlen anzustreben in dem die
grundlegenden verhaltensregeln a h und l
sowie eine selbst isolierung bei
krankheitssymptomen von der bevölkerung
weiter praktiziert werden indem wir
mit effektiver testung und
kontaktpersonen nachverfolgung die zahl
der neuinfektionen niedrig halten damit
der öffentliche gesundheitsdienst neu
auftretende fälle nachrücken kann damit
quarantäne und isolation überall wo
erforderlich praktiziert werden kann und
damit ausbruchs untersuchungen
durchgeführt werden können wir brauchen
einen umfassenden einsatz der
impfprävention wir können erkennen dass
im prävention hilft
ich erinnere an den 23 12 2020 als wir
in den nordrhein-westfälischen
pflegeheimen vor dem start der
impfkampagne eine anzahl von über 5200
infizierten menschen hatten die dadurch
in größte gefahr gekommen sind und wir
haben in dieser woche erlebt dass nach
dem praktisch alle bewohner von
altenheimen durchgeimpft sind in
nordrhein-westfalen die zahl der noch
von der krankheit befallenen in den
heimen auf 560 gesunken ist
das zeigt wie sehr im prävention wirkt
impfung ist eine starke waffe in der
auseinandersetzung mit der pandemie und
das zeigt auch dass wir mit der
intensivierung der impfkampagne den
schutz besonders gefährdeter
bevölkerungsgruppen ernst nehmen und
dass wir damit wirksam sind
das lka hat gestern seinen neuen bericht
zu besorgniserregenden saß koch 2 und
ihres varianten vorgestellt
die britische variante macht in
deutschland mittlerweile rund 46 prozent
aus zugleich haben wir rund 2800 cupid
19 patientinnen und patienten in
intensivmedizinischer behandlung
das entspricht dem rückstand der welle
im frühjahr 2020 der ersten welle und
allein das zeigt dass wir uns ohne jeden
zweifel weiter in einer epidemischen
lage von nationaler tragweite befinden
und deshalb ist es gut und richtig wenn
wir heute so fraktionsübergreifend wie
möglich auch dass rechtliche
fortbestehen nachdem infektionsschutz
über den 31 2021 wenn die derzeitige
feststellung ausläuft festhalten und für
die zeit ab april festlegen
ja oft über die rolle des deutschen
bundestages in der pandemie bekämpfung
debattiert und gerade nachdem gestern
die ministerpräsidenten der bundesländer
bei der bundeskanzlerin getagt haben
freue ich mich dass unser haus
fraktionsübergreifend so voll besetzt
ist wie es ist
und ich finde es nicht schlecht wenn wir
nicht nur immer hier die bundeskanzlerin
den bundesminister für gesundheit den
bundesminister für wirtschaft zur rede
stellen und zur verantwortung ziehen
würden ich rege an dass sich vielleicht
der eine oder andere ministerpräsident
auch mal überlegt ob er sich diesem haus
wahl stellt wenn er sowas veranstaltet
wie wir es gestern erlebt haben wir
haben konsequenzen aus den debatten
gezogen und diese konsequenzen sind im
wesentlichen dass wir eine
rechtsgrundlage für die impfverordnung
des bmg neu fassen und in das
infektionsschutzgesetz einzeln
wir haben uns darauf verständigt dass
wir über die inzidenz hinaus weitere
kriterien im gesetz festhalten sowohl
die frage der reproduktions zuvor als
auch die anzahl der geimpften als auch
die belastungssituation im
gesundheitswesen und wir haben uns
darauf verständigt dass wir eine
evaluation mit unabhängigen
wissenschaftlern betreiben die ihr
ergebnis bis ende 2021 vorlegen und dass
wir von der nächsten bundesregierung
erwarten sich dann dazu zu verhalten
sodass wir dann eine debatte darüber
kriegen welche konsequenzen für die
gestaltung des infektionsschutzgesetzes
daraus zu ziehen sind und wir haben uns
darauf verständigt dass wir bei den
kompetenzen die wir dem bundesminister
für gesundheit übertragen
durch die streichung des wortes
insbesondere an vier stellen eine
konkretisierung des auftrags vornehmen
und deswegen liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen glaube ich dass der bundestag
seine rolle mit der verabschiedung
dieses gesetzes stärkt und deswegen
bitte ich sie alle sehr herzlich um ihre
zustimmung vielen dank für die
aufmerksamkeit
[Applaus]
jetzt verteidigt das wort den kollegen
doktoren und afd
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident werde
kollegen frau bundeskanzlerin nur noch
ein drittel der bevölkerung halten eine
beibehaltung der korona maßnahmen für
sinnvoll
immer mehr mittelständler stellen sich
die existenzfrage und die psychischen
krankheiten durch den dauer lockdown
steigen exorbitant der mittelstand in
deutschland steht vor der schwersten
krise seit dem zweiten weltkrieg
arbeitslosigkeit betriebsschließung und
insolvenzen beherrschen in deutschland
die tagesordnung die korona pandemie ist
längst nicht mehr nur ein
gesundheitspolitisches sondern
mittlerweile auch ein
gesamtgesellschaftliches problem
umso unverständlicher ist es dass statt
kurz mittel und langfristige lösung ein
chaotisches krisenmanagement angeboten
wird mit fehlenden öffnungs und
unterstützungs perspektiven
wir brauchen kein gesetz für den
fortbestand einer epidemischen lage
was wir aber brauchen meine damen und
herren was wir in der tat brauchen ist
ein raster management welches die fdp
bereit seit februar 20 20 fordert dies
gilt es umzusetzen und aufmerksamkeit zu
schenken
aber was meine damen und herren ist denn
nun der große unterschied zu dem was
hier gerade in deutschland stattfindet
bei unserem raster management werden die
risikogruppen und erkranken bei
gleichzeitigen aufrechterhalten
systemrelevanter gesellschaftlicher und
wirtschaftlicher prozesse geschützt eine
indirekte bestätigung erfuhr ich dazu
bei einem gespräch mit dem chef des
russischen gesundheitsausschusses im
oktober letzten jahres kam doktor
morozov denn in russland setzt man ein
ähnliches konzept mit
expertenkommissionen ein wie wir die fds
fordern
ergänzt wird das ganze durch ein
staatlich organisierten freiwilligen
dienst um die risikogruppen und
erkrankten effektiv zu unterstützen
einen neuerlichen lockdown gab und gibt
es in russland nicht und schauen wir uns
die aktuellen daten der hopkins
universität an wird schnell deutlich
dass es keinen zusammenhang
ich betone keinen zusammenhang zwischen
dem 7 tages in sidenten und den
todesraten bei lockdown maßnahmen und
eben keinen lockdown maßnahmen gibt so
liegt zum beispiel die sieben tages
incidents wie auch die korona
todeszahlen bezogen auf die
gesamtbevölkerung um circa die hälfte
niedriger als in deutschland oder in
österreich
in anbetracht des weniger effizienten
gesundheitssystems in russland zeigt
sich deutlich dass es auf jeden fall an
dem management liegt und nicht primär an
der gesundheitsversorgung
trotz massiver kritik aus dem
gesundheitsausschuss besteht aus unserer
sicht eben kein widerspruch zwischen
einem effizienten expertenrat und der
forderung der aufhebung der feststellung
der epidemiologischen lage denn die
epidemiologische lage wird sozusagen
benutzt um grundrechts einschränke zu
grundrechts einschränkungen zu
legitimieren
deshalb plädieren wir für die sofortige
aufhebung der epidemischen lage von
nationaler tragweite zweiter für die
beseitigung der grundrechtseingriffe und
ermächtigung durch dieses gesetz und
drittens für die entwicklung eines
raster management konzeptes mit
expertenrat unter berücksichtigung der
drei säulen des pandemie management
schutz der risikogruppen medikamentöse
beeinflussung der virus ausbreitung und
last but not least prophylaxe sowie
impfstrategie auf freiwilliger basis
vielen dank für ihre aufmerksamkeit
[Applaus]
jetzt erhält das wort die kollegin
sabine dittmar spd sehr geehrter herr
präsident liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
fast genau vor einem jahr wusste das
parlament erstmals eine epidemische lage
von nationaler tragweite feststellen wir
haben damals gemeinsam mit dem ersten
bevölkerungsschutz gesetz wichtige
gesetzliche regelungen getroffen um
flexibel und schnell auf die
entwicklungen der sachskurve zwei
epidemie reagieren zu können
wir haben die band die bedingten
regelungen im infektionsschutzgesetz
damals für ein jahr befristet dies
geschah in der annahme dass corona
wollte schon längst der vergangenheit
angehören würde
leider ist das nicht der fall saß co wie
zwei hält weiterhin die welt in atem
mit fast 150 millionen erkrankten 25
millionen todesfällen und auch in
deutschland gibt es keine entwarnung
nach einem erfreulichen rückgang der
neuinfektionen befinden wir uns seit
mitte februar in einer seitwärtsbewegung
auf einem sehr hohen niveau
mit steigender tendenz das virus und
mittlerweile maßgeblich die wesentlich
infektiösen virus mutanten gegen kürze
auch das infektionsgeschehen bestimmen
werden erfordern deshalb weiterhin ein
konsequentes handeln von uns allen und
deshalb werden wir heute feststellen
dass die epidemische lage von nationaler
tragweite weiter besteht
wir werden weiter regeln dass wir nach
drei monaten keine erneute feststellung
erfolgt diese automatisch als aufgerufen
gilt und damit auch alle verbundenen
rechtsverordnungen und anordnungen ihre
gültigkeit verlieren und ich möchte an
dieser stelle einmal ganz deutlich
machen weil ich in vielen gesprächen den
eindruck gewinnen
dass es immer wieder vermischt wird wenn
der bundestag wurde das fortbestehen der
epidemischen lage fest stellt heißt das
nicht dass liegt zur bekämpfung von
kurbeln getroffenen maßnahmen auch auf
dauer verstehen
schritt für schritt wird zwischen bund
und ländern über lagerungsmöglichkeiten
und über notwendige und angemessene
einschränkungen beraten werden und die
länder müssen bei der umsetzung
begründen ob die maßnahmen geeignet
erforderlich und angemessen sind und
hierzu genügt es eben nicht sich
ausschließlich an den incidents werten
zu orientieren
wir müssen beispielsweise auch der
erwehrte belastung des
gesundheitssystems die impfquote oder
neue desk möglichkeiten mit
berücksichtigt werden und das haben wir
mit dem vorliegenden gesetzentwurf auch
noch mal ganz deutlich ich meine meine
damen kann ich kann den wunsch nach
lockerungen gut verstehen dass
lebensjahr allen bürgerinnen und bürger
gewerbetreibende touristik kultur
schaffen die wir alle brauchen eine
klare perspektive
und genau das ist auch die
herausforderung denn das abwägen
zwischen infektionsgeschehen und
weiteren lockerungen das für und wider
zwischen öffnen und aufrufen zum
durchhalten es ist und bleibt eine kraft
wandern und allerdings kann dieser
schmale grat mittlerweile mit etwas mehr
zuversicht beschritten werden wenn wir
den impfungen mit den tests und dank der
digitalen kontakt datenerfassung haben
wir neue und bessere möglichkeiten zur
verfügung und deshalb bin ich froh dass
die bund länder konferenz gestern nicht
nur über öffnung strategien sondern vor
allem auch über ins und test strategien
gesprochen hat bei den test strategien
bleiben für mich als medizinerin
allerdings noch einige fragen offen ein
test pro woche in schule und kita kann
nur ein anfang sein
ich begrüße dass wir nun endlich bei der
impfstrategie weiter kommen die großen
mengen an impfstoff dosen aufhalte die
sind für mich völlig unakzeptabel und
aus denen als ausgehenden des intervalls
zwischen erster und zweiter impfungen
abschmelzen der reserve für die
zweitimpfung und die hoffentlich zügige
anpassung der stiko empfehlung bezüglich
des einsatzes von astra tätig sind oder
signale und ich sage mit allem nachdruck
neben einer deutlichen
kapazitätssteigerung in den impfzentren
müssen jetzt sehr zeitnah die haus- und
facharztpraxen und auch die
betriebsärzte mit in die impfstrategie
integriert werden meine kleine damen und
herren zum ende meiner rede möchte ich
noch auf ein paar wichtige veränderungen
hinweisen die wir im parlamentarischen
verfahren erreicht haben auf die
rechtlichen feinheiten wird mein kollege
fechner eingehen aber für uns als
gesundheitspolitiker war es wichtig den
pflege schutzschirm unverändert
fortzuführen
da hatten wir auf die angedachten
regelung zu große unsicherheit bei den
einrichtungs trägern geführt ich hoffe
diese sorgen haben wir neben dem können
wir passen auch die
entschädigungsregelungen
infektionsschutzgesetz für eltern die
kante me bedingt in der betreuung
leisten an die bereits erweiterten
regelungen zum kinderkrankengeld im
sozialgesetzbuch an und wir haben die
prämienzahlung für besonders belastete
pflegekräfte und andere krankenhaus-
beschäftigte erheblich ausgeweitet
hierzu werden 450 millionen euro bereit
gestellt und ich denke die beschäftigten
haben diese prämie mehr als verdient
meine damen und herren insgesamt legen
wir ihnen ein gelungenes gesetz vor dass
im parlamentarischen verfahren wirklich
entscheidende veränderungen erfahren hat
und ich denke mit ein bisschen mehr
tempo beim team von einer gut
durchdachten test spaghetti oder alle
weiterhin achtsam und zwar völlig
miteinander umgehen werden wir ein stück
normalität zurück gewinnen
ich danke für die aufmerksamkeit bitte
um zustimmung zum gesetz und bleiben sie
gesund
[Applaus]
nächste rednerin ist die kollegin
christine aschenberg-dugnus fdp sehr
geehrter herr präsident liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen wir als fdp
bundestagsfraktion erkennen an dass sie
einige unserer forderungen in diesem
gesetzesentwurf umgesetzt haben
so begrüßen wir dass der bundestag
nunmehr mindestens alle drei monate der
feststellung der epidemischen lage
zustimmen muss das haben wir schon sehr
lange gefordert ebenso positiv ist dass
im ziele für die priorisierung jetzt im
gesetz aufgeführt werden und auch dass
bestimmte schutzschirme verlängert
werden das ist für die akteure sehr
wichtig leider haben sie es aber nicht
geschafft die verfassungsrechtlichen
verstöße die immer noch vorliegen
aufzuheben meine damen und herren von
ihnen als regierung wurde trotz
öffentlicher anhörung trotz einhelliger
auffassung der verfassungsrechtler trotz
einschätzung der leopoldina und des
ethikrates ganz einfach die menü taste
also die stummschaltung gedrückt und
einfach auf durchzug geschaltet das geht
nicht meine damen und herren ich frage
mich ernsthaft wo ist die
verfassungsrechtliche expertise der
koalition geblieben ich sehe da nichts
die feststellung der epidemischen lage
alle drei monate eröffnet dem
ministerium doch nach
wie vor die option innerhalb dieser drei
monate verordnungen ohne zustimmung des
bundestages festzustellen und das geht
nicht meine damen und herren eine solche
dauer genehmigung ist verfassungswidrig
sie umgehen hier den parlamentsvorbehalt
und das ist eine missachtung des
parlamentes
sie wollen einfach nicht akzeptieren
dass ihre verordnungsermächtigung ohne
beteiligung des bundestages einhellig
als verstoß gegen artikel 80 grundgesetz
von allen verfassungsrechtlern bewertet
wird meine damen und herren
außerdem ist die nennung von im zielen
für die priorisierung allein nicht
ausreichend auch das haben
verfassungsrechtler bestätigt eine impf
priorisierung die ja im moment leider
noch aufgrund der beschränkten
verfügbarkeit sein muss diese muss
gesetzlich normiert sein alles andere
ist verfassungswidrig und leider leider
stellen sie unseren regelungsvorschlag
immer wieder falsch da wenn sie
behaupten er wäre zu statisch und zu
unflexibel ich empfehle einfach mal
einen blick in unseren änderungsantrag
auch wir wollen eine
verordnungsermächtigung um schnell auf
neue impfstoffe oder auf eine anpassung
der priorisierung reagieren zu können
auch wir wollen flexibilität auch wir
wollen impfungen den arztpraxen und von
betriebsärzten aber und das weigern sie
sich leider zu akzeptieren das kann nur
mit zustimmung des deutschen bundestages
geschehen meine damen und herren und
genau das steht in unserem
änderungsantrag denn die frage wann wer
geimpft wird hat nunmal auswirkungen auf
leben und körperliche unversehrtheit der
menschen wir benötigen rechtssicherheit
und als fraktionen die die
rechtsstaatlichkeit sehr hoch hält ist
uns das besonders wichtig meine damen
und herren leider müssen wir aufgrund
des missmanagements bei der impfstoff
beschaffung auch weiterhin priorisiert
und deshalb kommt es beim wettlauf gegen
das virus aufs tempo beim impfen an
da hakt es noch gewaltig deswegen den
wir erneut in vorleistung und bringen
morgen einen antrag für ein nationales
im portal in den deutschen bundestag ein
das impfdosen auf halde liegen und nicht
schimpft werden dass es ein zustand den
wir nicht akzeptieren können und er
beendet werden muss meine damen und
herren das imb management der
bundesregierung hat der politik und dem
ansehen deutschlands einen schweren
schaden zugefügt platz 22 in europa
platz 40 in der welt das ist doch
einfach nicht hinnehmbar das ist doch
eine schande und das muss geändert
werden
desweiteren kritisieren wir an dem
gesetzentwurf dass die schutzschirme
nicht ausreichend aufgespannt werden es
fehlen wichtige akteure wie zb die
hebammen heilmittelerbringer und
zahnärzte die jetzt in dem schutzschirm
nicht berücksichtigt werden
im ergebnis werden wir ihr gesetz
ablehnt vielen dank
[Applaus]
nächste reden eine kollegin susanne
förster die linke herr präsident sehr
verehrte kolleginnen und kollegen die
pandemische lage besteht weiterhin das
belegen die aktuellen zahlen deswegen
sind auch weiter maßnahmen notwendig das
ist unstrittig
aber das ist hier seit einem jahr
erleben ist nichts anderes als chaos und
planlosigkeit
es fehlt nach wie vor an transparenz an
demokratischer beteiligung des
parlaments und an einer klaren strategie
gestern packte wieder die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz am
kanzlerin und mir kommt es langsam so
vor wie täglich grüßt das murmeltier
stunden langes spektakel im kanzleramt
drinnen und stundenlanges warten draußen
auf die ergebnisse ich weiß ich
wiederhole mich aber die debatten
gehören raus aus dem kanzleramt und rein
hier ins parlament
frau bundeskanzlerin halten seit einem
jahr nicht für notwendig zumindest vor
dieser runde hier eine öffentliche
regierungserklärung abzugeben nicht
einmal im nachgang das ist doch an
ignoranz kaum zu überbieten
öffentlichkeit würde für transparenz
sorgen und zu manchen wilden theorien
vorbeugen um so entsetzt da bin ich dass
union und spd gestern im
gesundheitsausschuss mit den stimmen der
afg einen unterausschuss beschlossen
haben der nicht öffentlich hinter
verschlossenen türen beraten soll
das schlägt dem fass den boden aus liebe
und lohnende es geht ich weiß nicht wie
sie ihre rolle verstehen aber unsere
aufgabe als parlamentarier ist es doch
für transparenz zu sorgen und
wesentliche entscheidungen selbst zu
treffen und nicht der bundesregierung zu
überlassen
auf die und die fragen ob man seinen
beruf beruf nachgehen kann
ob es ausgangssperren gibt ob schulen
und kitas geschlossen sind das sind doch
wohl wesentliche entscheidungen und im
übrigen auch die frage andersherum wann
wird denn wieder geöffnet das einzige
wesentliche was der bundestag in diesen
fragen beschlossen hat war vor circa
einem jahr eine umfassende
verordnungsermächtigung der
bundesregierung und auch der
landesregierungen
und was fällt ihnen nach einem jahr an
verbesserungen ein
der bundestag soll nun die epidemische
lage im drei monats rhythmus beschließen
tut er es nicht gelten auch alle
verordnungen die seit anfang 20 20 in
kraft getreten nicht mehr also auch
krankenhausfinanzierung arbeitsschutz
und so weiter das ist doch lediglich
eine schein beteiligung des parlaments
regierung per verordnung bleibt weiter
möglich das ist mit uns nicht zu machen
und es wird und sie hier
und was bezüglich der akzeptanz der
bevölkerung genauso ein großes problem
ist wie die fehlende transparenz das ist
die fehlende strategie im vorfeld und
auch im nachgang dieser
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz wird so
würde man zumindest in bayern sagen
regelmäßig eine andere sau durchs dorf
getrieben jeder und jede hat andere
ideen und andere vorschläge der eine
erzählt dass der osterurlaub nicht
möglich ist der nächste erzählt was von
bedeutenden schritten der eröffnung
dieses demnächst geben wird die inzidenz
werte die gestern diskutiert werden die
für die öffnungen maßgeblich sind
schwankten im stundentakt zwischen 35 50
und 100 es ist nicht mehr
nachvollziehbar und die bisherigen
öffnungszeiten zumindestens seltsam an
also während aktuell noch ganze
schulklassen im homeschooling sind haben
friseure seit erster märz wieder
geöffnet dass ich hab ja nicht
grundsätzlich was dagegen aber warum
ausgerechnet friseure und warum
ausgerechnet zum ersten märz und warum
sind eigentlich bayerische baumärkte
weniger infektiös als andere
ich sage ihnen das ist alles nicht
logisch das ist willkür und keine
strategie
wir sind uns einig alle freiheits
einschränkungen müssen so schnell wie
möglich aufgehoben werden
aber für öffnung szenarien ist kontakt
nachverfolgung ein breiter zugang zu
impfstoffen und schnelltests nötig und
bei allen diesen punkten hat die
bundesregierung bislang versagt die
krone waren app hat gefloppt und die
gesundheitsämter sind über einen viel zu
langen zeitpunkt runter gespart worden
so dass die kontakt verfolgung erschwert
wurde
ausreichender impfstoff steht nach wie
vor nicht zur verfügung auch weil sich
die bundesregierung standhaft weigert
die lizenzen freizugeben und auf die
angekündigten schnelltest und selbst es
warten wir noch während unsere
österreichischen nachbarn damit schon
lange
arbeiten ja natürlich ist die lage
dynamisch aber ein jahr nach der
pandemie können die menschen doch in
diesem land erwarten dass sie ordnung in
dieses chaos bringen und dazu gehört
einem parlament und ich betone im
parlament beschlossener stufenplan der
regelt welche einschränkungen und welche
bedingungen gelten und eine hier
beschlossene im pfund test strategien
das alles fehlt in ihrem gesetzesentwurf
und nach zwölf monaten hätte ich mir
wirklich mehr erwartet
und ich erwarte auch von dieser
bundesregierung dass sie die weichen für
die zukunft anders stellt wir brauchen
investitionen ins bildungssystem das was
in dieser pandemie mit kindern und
jugendlichen passiert ist das darf nie
wieder passieren und der gesundheits-
und pflegebereich muss endlich der
marktlogik entzogen werden es ist doch
völlig irre das im letzten jahr 20
krankenhäuser geschlossen worden sind
und abschließend bitte ich sie unserem
entschließungsantrag für eine
lohnersatzleistung für die pflegenden
angehörigen zuzustimmen
denn es sind menschen die sehr häufig
vergessen werden und die brauchen
unbedingt ein soziales sicherungspunkte
vielen dank nächste rednerin ist die
kollegin maria klein schmeink und muss
man sich das leben
[Applaus]
[Musik]
sehr geehrter herr präsident meine
lieben kolleginnen und kollegen hier im
hause wir diskutieren heute zwei
wichtige punkte unter diesem
tagesordnungspunkt in einer situation
die ausgesprochen gefährlich und
besonders wir sind in einer situation wo
die menschen es satthaben nicht mehr
nach draußen zu können mit all den
lieben die sie treffen wollen wo sie
große sehnsucht haben nach kontakt nach
kulturveranstaltungen nach erleben nach
gemeinsamkeit und gleichzeitig wissen
wir dass die virus varianten auf dem
vormarsch sind fast 50 prozent aller
infektionen sind mittlerweile gehen
mittlerweile auf diesen virus zurück und
dann und wir wissen dass das eine
gefährliche entwicklung ist die viele
unserer bemühungen der letzten monate
hinfällig machen kann und deshalb ist es
so wichtig besonnen und achtsam und
nachvollziehbar vorzugehen
und genau das passiert ja wir werden
heute der feststellung der fortsetzung
der epidemischen lage natürlich
zustimmen müssen wir sind in dieser
gefährlichen situation
das ist das eine aber wir sagen nein zu
diesem gesetzesentwurf der weiterhin
nicht vorsieht dass man im
infektionsschutzgesetz nachvollziehbar
findet was die politik tun wird was die
regierung tun wird in welcher lage war
welcher infektionsrate mit welchen
maßnahmen und aus welchen gründen
wir haben immer gefordert dass es einen
stufenplan geben muss der
verlässlichkeit schafft der
berechenbarkeit schafft der
nachvollziehbarkeit schafft und genau
das haben sie mit diesem gesetz nicht
und um zu zeigen wie das ist gestern
abend sind inzidenz werte beschlossen
worden die finden sich in diesem gesetz
überhaupt nicht wieder sie werden sofort
schon eine änderung des gesetzes machen
müssen um diese beschlüsse der mpk mit
der kanzlerin überhaupt umsetzen zu
können so ist dieser frage und das zeigt
sie haben es verschlafen sie haben es
nicht hingekriegt innerhalb von zwölf
monaten ein gesetz ein
infektionsschutzgesetz vorzulegen was
nachvollziehbar ist klar ist recht
sicher ist und damit den menschen
orientierung und klarheit bund bis sie
perspektiven gibt zusätzlich es steht
eine stringente test strategie die
selbst test kommen nicht vor
es fehlt eine wirkliche strategie für
die impfung auch da die risiken bleiben
weiterhin außen vor werden sehr sehr
schleppend nur mit terminen versuche
versorgt und es fehlt eine konsequente
und gute digital gestützte kontakt
nachverfolgung auch das haben sie
verschlafen und nicht auf den weg
gebracht ich muss sagen an dieser stelle
sie haben an vielen vielen stellen
versäumt wirklich voranzukommen die
menschen mitzunehmen und ihnen
orientierung und verlässlichkeit für die
nächsten wochen zu geben
[Applaus]
für die bundesregierung hat es
weitergeht bundesgesundheitsministerin
sparen
[Applaus]
herr präsident lieber kolleginnen und
kollegen alle sehen sich das ende dieser
pandemie herbei die zwölfjährige die
endlich wieder normal in die schule
gehen will und am nachmittag ihre
freunde vermisst
die 90-jährige im pflegeheim die gerne
wieder unbedacht besuch von kindern
enkeln und urenkeln hätte der
freiberufliche musiker dessen existenz
von konzerten abhängt die aktuell nicht
stattfinden können drei von unzähligen
beispielen ich kenne niemanden der diese
pandemie nicht leid ist
niemand möchte einschränkungen einen tag
länger als nötig aber wir sind noch in
einer besonderen lage
die pandemie ist noch nicht am ende das
zeigen die zahlen in den
intensivstationen die zahl der kurve 19
patienten die immer noch zu behandeln
sind das zeigen die infektionszahlen das
zeigt im übrigen auch der blick in
unserer europäischen nachbarländer
deshalb ist es richtig wenn wir als
bundestag heute feststellen dass die
epidemische lage weiterhin andauert denn
das entspricht der lage auch wegen der
mutation ist die lage dynamisch das
virus verändert sich die flexible
anpassung bleibt daher notwendige
strategie und gerade in dieser
schwierigen phase frau klein schmeink
hat darauf hingewiesen
es ist schwierig die richtige balance zu
finden dem bedürfnis nach normalität
wir spüren hier alle nach zwölf monaten
der pandemie diese sehnsucht
nach normalität ja auch viele nerven
wund gescheuert sind und gleichzeitig
der notwendigkeit eben diese pandemie
unter kontrolle zu halten und wir ringen
abgeordnete fraktionen
ministerpräsidenten
wir suchen den ausgleich der interessen
so wie gestern zehn stunden bund und
länder es geht ja um was
deswegen ist es auch richtig dass
gerungen wird es geht nicht um absolute
wahrheiten es geht um abwägen und das
finden der richtigen balance nicht der
einzelne gewinnt bei solchen abwägungen
sondern wir gemeinsam weil es um
schadensbegrenzung geht um balance
zwischen gesundheitsschutz und
wirtschaftlichen folgen und sozialen
härten dreh und angelpunkt ist die
feststellung der epidemischen lage von
nationaler tragweite durch den deutschen
bundestag das parlament überführt die
rechtsgrundlage für diese feststellung
nun in eine dauerhafte regelung
erstmalig haben wir damit eine pandemie
gesetzgebung in deutschland fest
verankert das ist eine neue qualität
ein großer schritt ja ein schritt wo wir
aus den lehren aus dieser noch an wahl
währenden pandemie weiter leer auch
schlüsse ziehen wollen
das hat der bundestag sozusagen mit dem
gesetz sich selbst aufgegeben nach ende
der pandemie diese rechtsgrundlage
weiter zu entwickeln gemeinsam mit der
bundesregierung aber die grundlage ist
gelegt und von den vielen wichtigen
regelung würde ich auf 2 1 geben ich bin
dankbar dass bund und länder gäste an
unseren vorschlägen auf meinen
vorschlägen beim testen und beim impfen
gefolgt sind stehen mehr tests zur
verfügung bei den schnelltest übersteigt
das angebot mittlerweile deutlich die
nachfrage die selbsttests werden in den
nächsten tagen nach den ersten
zulassungen an vielen stellen im land
nach und nach wächst auf aber verfügbar
sein
ab dem 8 tatsächlich eine woche später
ab nächsten montag wird der bund die
kosten für ein bürger test übernehmen
alle können sich regelmäßig kostenlos in
einem depot zentren vor ort testen
lassen
die länder haben deutlich gemacht dass
das angebot nicht gleich überall
gleichmäßig da sein wird aber viele sehr
vielen ländern auch gesagt dass sie
stadler sind wir setzen auf vielfalt vor
ort wird pragmatisch umgesetzt flexibel
kreativ in böblingen in tübingen
schmalkalden in vielen anderen
landkreisen bereits der bund setzt den
rahmen rechtlich und finanziell der bund
übernimmt die kosten umgesetzt wird vor
ort
dafür muss der bund auch gar nicht wie
ich heute lese die tests irgendwie
zentral beschaffen
das ist zentrale planung wird meistens
den gegebenheiten vor ort gar nicht
gerecht die tests sind verfügbar wir
setzen den rahmen
wir haben eine gemeinsame strategie in
welchen kontexten wer wie häufig
getestet wird und dann wird das vor ort
gelebt das ist bis jetzt ein sehr gutes
erfolgsrezept in dieser pandemie und das
setzen wir auf grundlage dieses gesetzes
vor und zum impfen impfen wirkt das
sehen wir jetzt schon der kollege henker
darauf hingewiesen über fünfeinhalb
prozent der deutschen sind geimpft
zuerst die besonders verwundbare und wir
sehen die täglichen meldungen wie der
schutz
dabei wächst ab april werden die
arztpraxen routinemäßig mit impfen
jeden tag zigtausende hunderttausende
später millionen wir müssen schneller
werden weil der impfstoff am anfang
knapp kommt er jetzt in steigende menge
impfdosen die da sind müssen
schnellstmöglich verimpft werden in den
impfzentren der länder in den arztpraxen
später auch bei den betriebsärzten das
ist die berechtigte erwartung der
bürgerinnen und bürger
das ist auch meine erwartung und mein
ziel als bundesminister
für gesund werden und auch der rahmen
für das impfen die organisation die
finanzierung die noch notwendige
priorisierung all das fußt in diesem
gesetz und auf der feststellung der
epidemischen lage und daher herr
präsident liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
umsicht beim öffnen hin zu mehr
normalität
wir testen um diesen weg zu mehr
normalität abzusichern schneller impfen
um den beschwerlichen weg raus aus der
pandemie unumkehrbar zu machen
das wird nun das zweite frühjahr in der
pandemie wir sind noch mittendrin
das virus hat noch nicht aufgegeben aber
alles spricht dafür
alles spricht dafür dass das das letzte
frühjahr in dieser pandemie wird um sich
testen impfen machen das möglich dafür
legt dieses gesetz die grundlage und
daher bitte ich um ihre zustimmung
[Applaus]
stefan brandt nach afd ist der nächste
video
[Applaus]
herr präsident meine damen und herren in
der zweiten hälfte dieser debatte stellt
sich eine grundsätzliche frage nämlich
die nach dem warum warum wir diese
debatte hier und heute eigentlich
geführt und weil ich am rednerpult
stehen meine damen und herren
beantwortet die frage gleich selber weil
merkel und co es nicht können
seit über einem jahr gelingt es diese
regierung nicht die krone
herausforderungen auch nur ansatzweise
in den griff zu bekommen denn über einem
jahr wird hilflos und planlos herum
dediziert erst gar nicht und wenn dann
falsch addierten versucht eine krise im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert mit den
mitteln des 16ten jahrhunderts in den
griff zu bekommen
im mittelpunkt dieses erbärmlichen
treiben steht ein vollkommen überfordert
jens spahn bankkaufmann 14 jahre student
und ex pharmalobby ist er steckt einen
erheblichen teil seiner energie in
dubiose immobiliengeschäfte
mitten in der krise wurde er eigentümer
einer millionenteuren luxusvilla eine
immobilie erwarb ja ob zum marktpreis
ersparen weiß ich nicht von einem mann
der danach mit klobigen gehalt
geschäftsführer einer vom bund
beherrschten gmbh wurde und wie
praktisch in einer seiner wohnungen lebt
fdp chef christian lindner sehr viel
zeit verwendet entspannen auch darauf
medienberichterstattung über sein
fragwürdiges treiben zu unterbinden und
journalisten auszuspionieren die ihm und
seinen machenschaften auf die schliche
kommen wollen und wenn er nicht gerade
beim notar ist und damit seinen anwälten
spricht dann predigt er verzicht treibt
sich aber gerne auf partys herum an
denen man gegen eine spende von
läppischen 9.999 euro teilnehmen darf
9.999 euro
damit es nicht im bundestags präsidentin
gefährdet gemeldet werden muss wasser
predigen und schampus aus kübeln trinken
das ist das motto des jens spahn meine
damen und herren
wenn herr spahn ein guter minister wäre
könnte man ihm das nachsehen und
verzeihen aber er ist das gegenteil
komplettversagen überall erst nutzen
masken nichts dann plötzlich sind sie
pflicht erste reicht ein tuch oder einen
schal oder irgendwas dann muss eine
medizinische maske sein impfstoff ist
erst keiner da und wenn er da ist wie
die kaum einer haben das ist
besser organisiert ersparen selbst test
ja oder nein wenn ja und wie viele und
wer bezahlt nur herumgeeiere krone.at
ein flop er wehrt instanzen alles
willkürlich festgelegt meine damen und
herren kurzem hat beim versagen in der
korona krise steht einer ganz vorne
und das ist jens spahn knapp dahinter
übrigens die merkel trompeter altmaier
und das gesamte kabinett aber auch die
ministerpräsidenten lassen sich da nicht
lumpen denn sie reagieren ja alle
irgendwo mit mein name ist dann wäre da
noch ein riesiger korruptionssumpf der
sich auftut zur zeit beschränkt auf die
union aber andere werden folgen ich sage
nur nüßlein ehemaliger oder ist das noch
fraktions vize der bundestagsfraktion
ist schon aufgeflogen verdachts auf
bestechlichkeit steuerhinterziehung
600.000 euro soll er als masken lobbyist
eingesteckt haben spuren führen wohin
ins gesundheitsministerium eine art der
spuren führen auch in den amigo sumpf in
bayern die namen stroms tauchen auf der
name tanzler ehemaliger finanzminister
taucht auf meine damen und herren
schüler taucht auf laschet in nordrhein
westfalen über seinen sohn in millionen
teure geschäfte verwickelt alle studios
das stinkt aus unserer sicht zum himmel
es zeigt sich also zusammenfassend alles
in allem ein jahr des total versagens
dieser regierung flankiert vom und
basierend auf der so genannten
epidemischen lage von nationaler
tragweite die heute verlängert werden
soll meinen diese notstandsgesetzgebung
trägt wie ausgeführt wird und ihre
blüten und öffnet vetternwirtschaft und
korruption tür und tor lassen sie uns
das hier und heute beenden und lehnen
sie alle die sie für grundrechte und
verantwortlichkeit stehen und
verantwortliche irgendwann mit den
steuergeldern leben sie mit uns
gemeinsam diese anträge alle ab und
beenden sie die epidemische lage mit
nationaler tragweite hier und heute
vielen dank
[Applaus]
nächste rednerin ist die kollegin hilde
mattheis spd
[Applaus]
herr präsident
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen gestern
wurde in der presse veröffentlicht der
verfassungsschutz stuft die gesamte afg
als verdachtsfall ein
ich glaube mehr braucht man dazu gar
nicht zu sagen uns geht es heute darum
uns geht es heute darum parlamentarische
demokratie zu festigen und das tun wir
mit diesem gesetz heute mit der
fortgeltung dieses gesetzes und keiner
von uns hat sich letztes jahr vorstellen
mögen dass wir dieses mal und heute in
der lage sein müssen weitere drei monate
diese situation die pandemische
notsituation festzustellen jeder hat
sich gewünscht sehr schnell zur
normalität zurückzukommen sehr schnell
auch wieder öffnungs strategien massiv
fahren zu können niemand hat sich
gewünscht dass incident zahlen weiter zu
unserem alltag gehören müssen
deshalb lassen sie uns hier heute als
parlament in der verantwortung auch für
die situation hier bei uns im land
miteinander klären wir wollen erstens
dass alle schutzmaßnahmen die wir
ergriffen haben weiter fort gelten
zweitens wir wollen die impfstrategie
verbessern und fortentwickeln und unsere
schimpf ziele besser formulieren und
drittens wir wollen in eine tatsächliche
test strategie geben und natürlich
überlagert das was gestern die
ministerpräsidentinnen und präsidenten
mit der bundeskanzlerin vereinbart haben
auch unsere debatte hier heute manch
einer wir haben es uns gewünscht dass
ein stufenplan sehr schnell auf eine
perspektive eröffnet ein stufenplan
vermittelt in der bevölkerung wir haben
einen
und sehr schnell wollten wir dass eine
test strategie tatsächlich auch so
umgesetzt wird das in der bevölkerung
klar ist jeder hat gleichermaßen jeder
hat gleichermaßen den zugang dazu
wir alle wollen vorsichtig seien
weiterhin und leider muss man sagen ist
das was gestern vereinbart worden ist
zwei schritte vor einer zurück
das ist schade und das bemerke ich auch
und ich glaube da müssen wir als
parlamentarier innen und parlamentarier
und ersparen hat ja gesagt uns obliegt
die rahmen geben drei milliarden pro
woche aufgrund der korona krise gut
angelegtes geld wichtig angelegtes geld
darauf aufgesetzt brauchen wir eine test
strategie die genauso eine option aus
offenbart und möglich machten option
dass menschen an ostern früher danach
wieder eine möglichkeit der
gesellschaftlichen teilhabe haben
mir ist diese test strategie keine
strategie sondern ein schritt der viele
weitere notwendig macht und ich glaube
dass wir wenn wir diese test strategie
verfolgt dann kriegen wir auch die
perspektive hin nicht vorher
und ich möchte mir nicht vorstellen
müssen dass das was gestern vereinbart
worden ist
ein test überwacht pro woche in
irgendeinem verwaltungs chaos wieder
untergeht und wir es nicht hinbekommen
dass klar ist wo wird getestet hat
jemand wirklich nur einmal pro woche
diesen test in anspruch genommen sondern
ich möchte
wir möchten dass diese eigenen test zu
unserem alltag gehören
denn nur so können wir in der tat
schritt für schritt mit diesen eigenen
test auch eine öffnung hinbekommen und
ich möchte nicht dass in sechs monaten
noch das thema incident saal masken
pflicht zum alltag unserer kinder gehört
ich möchte das auch in sechs monaten
nicht nur sommer da ist sondern auch ein
normales leben und dafür sollten wir
gemeinsam streiten vielen dank
[Applaus]
nicole vastic fdp die nächste reden herr
präsident
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen lassen
sie mich mit dem positiven beginnen
gut dass sie liebe kolleginnen kollegen
der groko einige forderungen unserer
änderungsanträge aufgenommen und ihren
gesetzentwurf nachgebessert haben es ist
richtig die korona bedingten
mindereinnahmen von pflegeheim weiterhin
auszugleichen
die pflegerische infrastruktur
einzuschränken wie sie es erst vorher
hatten wäre das völlig falsche signal
zum völlig falschen zeitpunkt gleiches
gilt für die pflegehilfsmittel pauschale
aber meine damen und herren damit
erschöpfen sich die guten nachrichten
dann auch denn bei zahnärzten hebammen
und heilmittel erbringen haben sie nicht
nachgebessert
diese lassen sie mit einmalzahlungen und
unzureichenden hilfen im regen stehen so
gefährden sie die versorgungslandschaft
und das kritisieren wir die erneute
corona prämie ist ein gutes zeichen für
die beschäftigten in den kliniken es
bleibt allerdings halbherzig solange die
steuerfreiheit der prämie nicht geklärt
ist
und eines ist auch klar mit 1000 euro
lässt sich die überfällige anerkennung
in der pflege nicht kaufen der korona
bonus entbindet sie herr minister nicht
von der pflicht endlich für nachhaltige
verbesserungen in der pflege zu sorgen
im herbst
haben sie noch vollmundig eine
pflegereform in der bild zeitung
angekündigt jetzt schlummert die reform
in irgendeiner schublade
doch kommen wir zurück zur fortgeltung
der epidemischen lage herr minister
sparen vor einem jahr hat der deutsche
bundestag sie mit befugnissen
ausgestattet die man sich vor der
pandemie in unserer parlamentarischen
demokratie nicht hätte vorstellen können
die bürgerinnen und bürger haben sich
seither mit beispielhafter disziplin an
die korona maßnahmen gehalten
sie haben ein recht darauf dass der
minister diese umfangreichen befugnissen
nutzen um die pandemie bestmöglich zu
managen
stattdessen fährt man seit einem jahr
auf sicht lockdown scheint zur
dauerlösung zu werden es wird agiert als
ob es auf den tag nicht ankäme
dabei zählt jeder tag denn jeder tag
kostet leben jeder tag kostet existenzen
und jeder tag vernichtet bildungschancen
für junge menschen mit einem stufenplan
der den gesundheitsschutz achtet können
wir den menschen endlich wieder eine
perspektive geben eine solche strategie
zu entwickeln ist lange überfällig und
das nicht in irgendeinem hinterzimmer
sondern hier im parlament beenden sie
das schneckentempo band impfen und
flankieren sie dies mit klugen test
konzepten sorgen sie dafür dass unser
land nicht zum schlusslicht in der
pandemie bekämpfung wird vielen dank
drogba manuela rottmann bündnis 90 die
grünen nicht die nächste rednerin
sehr geehrter herr präsident sehr
geehrte damen und herren sehr geehrter
herr bundesminister jens spahn
ich vermute irgendjemand rät ihnen zu
diesem rhetorischen trick den sie jedes
mal anwenden nämlich dann wenn die leute
außer sich sind inspirierender
langweiligkeit hier zu reden und dann
wenn sie keinen plan mehr haben das wort
gemeinsamkeit in den raum zu stellen
ich muss ihnen sagen ich hoffe sie haben
viel geld für diesen abo zahlt er
funktioniert nicht mehr
liebe kollegin sabine dittmar lieber
rudolf henke liebe hilde mattheis sie
arbeiten sich hier alle an den
beschlüssen ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
von gestern ab und ich frage mich
allmählich ob sie noch was merken sie
sind mitglied dieser regierungskoalition
mitglied der mehrheit hier im parlament
klare regelungen zu schaffen die die
gefahren für die gesundheitsversorgung
und die zu ihrer eindämmung zulässigen
grundrechtseingriffen dann verhältnis
setzt das ist der job abzuwägen ob im
fortschritt testmöglichkeiten nach
versorgungskapazitäten gesundheitsämter
alternativen zu beschränkungen
ermöglicht es ihr job und das sind
bürgerinnen und bürgern endlich
nachvollziehbar zu erklären alles tier
job der gesetzliche stufenplan ist die
einzige
wir sind für dieses problem zu
vorhersehbar zeit für rechtssicherheit
für verhältnismäßigkeit was sie uns aber
heute vorlegen das ist die verstetigung
des weiterwursteln es bleibt bei
worthülsen die breit angelegte und
umfassende schutzmaßnahmen das
verfallsdatum für verordnung wird ganz
abgeschafft jede inhaltliche steuerung
der pandemie bekämpfung durch das
parlament geben sie auf entweder ist die
lage ganz schlimm dann muss der
verordnung alles gehen oder sie ist
vorbei jedes schulkind in deutschland
hat mittlerweile eine differenziertere
sicht auf die pandemie als die autoren
dieses gesetzentwurfs keine einzige der
verabredungen von gestern findet sich
hier wieder von der sogenannten
notbremse vom heiligen uhr und deshalb
genau deshalb droht sie im ernstfall zu
versagen
gestalten sie eine zwischenfrage des
kollegen konnten nein die
grundrechtseingriffe vertiefen sich mit
jedem weiteren tag die begründung
pflaster für steigt und in dieser
situation riskieren sie dass uns die
instrumente zur abwehr der letzten welle
vor gericht in den händen zerrinnen und
das liegt nicht daran dass die gerichte
bösen willens sind oder den ernst der
lage nicht erkannt haben ich glaube sie
haben ihn nicht erkannt sie begründen so
schlecht wie soll man aber etwas
gedulden kann wenn man die beratung
durch ein pandemie rat seit einem jahr
stuhr ablehnt wenn man jetzt erst
anfangen will sich mit der frage zu
befassen wie die maßnahmen überhaupt
wirken und es einem nicht so peinlich
ist das ergebnis dazu im märz 2022
anzukündigen
auf den letzten metern setzen sie
mutwillig alles aufs spiel die erfolge
der bisherigen einschränkungen und die
bereitschaft der bevölkerung mitzuwirken
und deswegen lehnen wir dieses gesetz ab
früher galt die
die koalition einmal als bollwerk in der
krise ich will ihnen sagen das ist mit
dem heutigen tag vorbei jetzt ja gar
nicht das wort kollege drv gedreht
[Applaus]
särge der präsident sehr geehrte damen
und herren liebe koalition blicken sie
eigentlich noch durch wir in uns vor
einem jahr war das kona virus in ihren
worten beherrschte und seitdem
verstolpern sie nahezu jede maßnahme ob
abstand pcr-test masken die einen oder
die anderen oder gar keine lockdown
schnelltests oder impfungen
offenbar sind all diese dinge für sie
nach wie vor ein medizinisches buch mit
sieben siegeln
daher bekommen sie grundlegende
wissenschaftliche probleme nicht in den
griff
noch heute sind beim rk ii 3 test
derselben person statistisch drei
einzelne fälle
damit ist die statistik wertlos das kann
ihnen jeder student im grundstudium
sagen todes teil 1 kommt mit wochen
verspätung sie passen also nie zu den
gemeldeten zahlen die wir vermutlich
alle täglich konsumieren sie ignorieren
dass ein pcr test keine infektion
anzeigen kann
auch das mehrfach festgestellt was
messen sie dann eigentlich womit
ängstigen sie die bevölkerung auf
welchen werten basieren sie ihre
maßnahmen
studien zeigen dass sie über die
biologisch nichts bringt ja was tun sie
eigentlich sie bedauern dass kinder und
jugendlichen wertvolle lebenszeit
gestohlen wird das ist richtig dann
bekommen sie endlich die medizinischen
grundlagen in den griff sie schüren
angst vor virus mutationen in den
letzten wochen dafür sind diese
medizinisch völlig normal
bei grippe redet kein mensch darüber und
sie sind kein grund zur panik
seit einem jahr setzten sie das normale
leben in deutschland außer kraft dabei
haben wir als politiker vor allem eine
aufgabe bürger und unternehmen in ruhe
zu lassen und uns als ihrem privat
berufsleben herauszuhalten
nicht gerade hat dieses land gefangen
meine damen und herren sie sind es
lassen sie unser land endlich frei und
beenden die epidemische lage und den
lockdown ich traf hinweise sondern
konsequent und vollständig
nina war pdc sich den extra drin
[Applaus]
herr präsident sehr geehrte kolleginnen
und kollegen in dieser krisensituation
in der wir uns trotz auf positive
entwicklungen befinden ist das gesetz
zur fortgeltung der regelungen über die
epidemische lage ein weiterer wichtiger
und richtiger schritt zur bekämpfung der
korona pandemie besorgen durch maßvolle
änderungen dafür dass die notwendigen
regelungen zur überwindung der krise in
der erforderlichen weise fortgeführt und
an die gegebenheiten angepasst werden
können
kernpunkt ist künftig überprüft der
bundestag in kurzen und regelmäßigen
abständen ob diese epidemische lage nach
wie vor gegeben ist die feststellung der
epidemischen lage tritt automatisch
außer kraft wenn sie nicht spätestens
binnen drei monaten durch den bundestag
erneut bestätigt wird und du bist ganz
deutlich zu sagen der stelle also keinen
blankoscheck aus wie es immer wieder
heißt im gegenteil der bundestag wird
stärker in den entscheidungsprozess
eingezogen
damit gilt auch für die zukunft die
befugnisse zur bewältigung der pandemie
werden auf zeit erteilt und kommt
regelmäßig künftig in festgelegten und
kürzeren fristen auf den prüfstand die
beteiligungsrechte des bundestages
werden noch einmal gestärkt auch wenn
manche kollegen dass hier nicht
verstehen und wenn man dann am thema
vorbei redet wie der kollege brandner
ist man dafür dann auch selbst
verantwortlich
der erde damen und herren dass all diese
befugnisse hoffentlich nicht mehr lange
nötig sein werden das ist natürlich
unser aller hoffnung und das gemeinsame
ziel auf das wir hinarbeiten
doch in der gegenwärtigen situation ist
es schlicht unumgänglich dass die
voraussetzungen für eine wirksame
bekämpfung der korona pandemie gesichert
bleiben und auch weiterentwickelt werden
die gefahr durch das virus besteht nicht
nur fort die aktuelle situation wird
noch verschärft durch das auftreten
neuer virus
varianten daher bleibt das vorrangige
ziel mit geeigneten und situations
abgestimmte schutzmaßnahmen die
ausbreitung der pandemie zu verhindern
und sie zu bekämpfen und leben und
gesundheit der menschen zu schützen
nur so stellen wir auch die
funktionsfähigkeit unseres
gesundheitssystems sicher und schützen
uns vor und überlastung und das schaffen
wir durch dieses gesetz und an die
kolleginnen der grünen gerichtet wir
sind hier schon auch eine antwort
schuldig geblieben wie sie denn mit der
dynamischen lage umgehen wollen sie
wären uns planlosigkeit vor was ihr plan
ist das haben wir aber in den
wortbeiträgen auch nicht gehört sehr
geehrte damen und herren
und da es hier auch oft gesagt wird
möchte ich an dieser stelle klar zum
ausdruck bringen dass wir stärker darauf
achten müssen dass wir die wesentlichen
grundrecht relevanten fragen im
parlament selbst entscheiden und das
genau machen wir heute wir legen mit
diesem gesetz klare und
ausdifferenzierte rechtsgrundlagen vor
darüber hinaus geben wir der
bundesregierung dem
bundesgesundheitsminister die
ermächtigung durch rechtsverordnung
gezielt und schnell auf
herausforderungen reagieren zu können
wir präzisieren im gesetz auch die
vorgaben für die maßgaben maßnahmen der
länder in dem wir fest schreiben dass
bei erwägungen über öffnungs schritte
oder andere erleichterungen nicht nur
die zahl der infektionen sondern auch
die impfquote unter wert zu
berücksichtigen sind auch normieren wir
das virus mutationen bei der abwägung
welche maßnahmen zu treffen sind
besonders berücksichtigt werden können
sehr geehrte damen und herren wir
befinden uns momentan in einer
ausnahmesituation und diese
ausnahmesituation bedarf auch
außergewöhnliche maßnahmen gerade
deswegen ist es uns wichtig dass wir die
getroffenen massnahmen laufend bewerten
und daher setzen wir zum jahresende
sehen wir vor dass die maßnahmen der
krisenbekämpfung von einem unabhängigen
und interdisziplinären
wissenschaftlichen gremiums wieder zu
werden
wir lassen damit unser handeln in der
ausnahmesituation überprüfen und
schreiben das im gesetz auch fest unser
handeln meine lieben kolleginnen und
kollegen soll für die bürgerinnen und
bürger noch nachvollziehbarer und
verständlicher werden und anhand der
erfahrungen passen wir die gesetze
maßvoll an und das ist es doch sehr
geehrte damen und herren was mir und was
allen demokratischen parteien in diesem
hohen haus ganz besonders wichtig sein
sollte
sehr geehrte damen und herren diese
grundlagen geben uns die notwendige
flexibilität um wie bereits erwähnt auf
virus mutationen reagieren zu können so
können auch anpassungen an die sich
ändernde pandemische lage vorgenommen
werden zusammenfassend lässt sich also
feststellen dass wir mit dem
vorliegenden gesetzentwurf ein gut
weiterentwickelt das instrumentarium zur
verfügung stellen mit dem wir rechts
sicher auf die epidemische lage
reagieren können wir führen mit dem
gesetz einen griechen diesen mechanismus
ein und wir erweitern die kriterien und
gestalten sie differenzierter aus ich
werbe daher nicht nur für die zustimmung
zu diesem gesetz werde kolleginnen und
kollegen wir können in der pandemie
nicht allein mit gesetze und
verordnungen handeln und die pandemie
damit bekämpfen wir schaffen hier zwar
eine gute grundlage wir brauchen aber
auch die bürgerinnen und bürger deshalb
lassen sie uns auch gemeinsam bei den zu
recht pandemie müden bürgerinnen und
bürgern für dieses gesetz und für unser
handeln werden
herzlichen dank
[Applaus]
jetzt habe ich das wort den kollegen
mario mirror
vielen dank herr präsident sie sehr
geehrte damen und herren am 18.11 des
letzten jahres hat sich dieses parlament
mit der zustimmung zum
infektionsschutzgesetz selbst entmachtet
und auch wenn insbesondere die fdp und
die linken heute lautstark die fehlende
parlamentarische mitbestimmung so alle
haben den änderungsantrag der lk er der
damals genau das förderte mit abgelehnt
eingriffe in die grundrechte in leben
wirtschaft und gesellschaft erfordern
vertrauen und verhältnismäßigkeit gehen
wir diese bilanz einmal durch zu beginn
der situation die einschätzung ist es
eine grippe ist das schlimmer eine
grippe als eine grippe sind masken
sinnvoll ja oder nein wurde bereits
vertrauen verspielt in der folge masken
beschaffung umgang mit pflegekräften
auszahlung hilfsgelder impfstoff
beschaffung im pläne und jetzt
mittlerweile auch die beschaffung der
selbsttest überall hat diese regierung
vertrauen verspielt erst basierten die
maßnahmen auf dem erwert dann auf den
wissenswert und jetzt wird die
fortführung der einschränkung
ausschließlich mit neuen mutationen
begründet aber viren mutieren nunmal
dauernd und so könnten sie uns in einen
ewigen dauer lockdown schicken
für die bürger ist das alles völlig
willkürlich es gibt keine
planungssicherheit keine fakten keine
richtwerte sondern eine dynamische lage
die sie gar nicht zu definieren wissen
und wahrscheinlich auch gar nicht
definieren wollen wenn es steht ja der
wahlkampf vor der tür
warum soll ihren nach diesen erfahrungen
noch irgendjemand der steuerzahler
trauen die antwort auf bewohner kann das
nicht sein das virus zu leugnen und gar
nichts zu tun
wer aber tragfähige konzepte entwickelt
habe er hat es nicht verdient dass man
ihnen anschließend mit dem lockdown
hammer die lebensgrundlage entzieht und
noch nach teuren investitionen von
hinten umgegrätscht und doch alles zu
macht aber ich lehne den antrag nicht
nur wegen seiner fragwürdigen grundlagen
und seiner existenzbedrohenden
auswirkungen auf familien mittelständler
künstler und selbstständige ab ich lehne
ihn speziell als abgeordneter dieses
hohen hauses ab sie alle haben sich
hierher wählen lassen um verantwortung
zu tragen
dann werden sie dem auch gerecht dieser
bundestag ist das gremium
in dem die politik für dieses land
entschieden wird und nicht wie jetzt
vorgeschlagen in irgendwelchen räten und
schon gar nicht in kandy kratzwunden
vielen dank
nächster redner ist der kollege dr
johannes fechner spd herr präsident
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen die
infektionszahlen sind bei weitem nicht
mehr so hoch wie sie schon waren die
impfungen laufen an und es stehen
demnächst auch tests in viel größerer
zahl zur verfügung all das sind schritte
in die richtige richtung aber wir müssen
eben auch feststellen dass die
schutzmaßnahmen der länder für die
unternehmen und für die familien massive
negative beeinträchtigungen haben die
familien sind am limit viele unternehmen
stehen vor dem aus und deswegen ist für
mich eines klar diese weitreichenden
schutzmaßnahmen diese
grundrechtseingriffe müssen immer wieder
genauestens überprüft werden ob sie
überhaupt noch erforderlich sind liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen und diese
fragestellung der erforderlichkeit die
nehmen wir heute mit diesem gesetz auf
den schutzmaßnahmen sind erhebliche
eingriffs grundrechtseingriffe ausgangs
sperrungen schulschließungen und
ähnliches und deswegen können wir diese
maßnahmen nicht nur allein am incidents
wert 35 oder 50 orientieren und das
ändern wir heute mit diesem gesetz liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen der deutsche
ethikrat hat in seiner stellungnahme
ausdrücklich gesagt ich zitiere das
nicht die ausbreitung des virus als
solches entscheidend sei sondern
vielmehr nur gravierende negative folgen
wie etwa eine hohe sterblichkeit
langfristige gesundheitliche
beeinträchtigung signet verdeckt
signifikanter bevölkerungsteile oder der
drohende kollaps des gesundheitssystems
und genau aus diesen gründen war es uns
als spd so wichtig dass wir im
infektionsschutzgesetz eine klare
regelung haben das nicht nur einzig und
allein der inzidenz wert sondern auch
die auslastung des gesundheitswesens der
erwerb oder die impfquote berücksichtigt
werden müssen und zwar zwingend
wenn dann wenn jetzt wahlkampf wäre
würde ich sagen dass das die spd
durchgesetzt hat da gab es erhebliche
widerstände bei der union gut dass wir
diese gesetzesänderung jetzt heute so
beschließen können denn die grundrechte
wie bewegungsfreiheit oder der
werbefreiheit das können wir nur dann
einschränken wenn es tatsächlich
erforderlich ist und deswegen müssen
hier an weitere kriterien angreifen als
die inzidenz werte und wenn jetzt gesagt
wird dass wir eine verfassungswidrige
regelung hier beschlossen wäre dann ist
das schlicht unzutreffend denn wir
stärken doch gerade die rolle des
parlamentes weil wir als parlament und
als volksvertretung eine evaluierung mit
einer klaren befristung mit einem klaren
untersuchungsauftrag beschlossen haben
wir beschränken die befugnisse des
bundesgesundheitsministers er wird
zukünftig nur genau die maßnahmen machen
können die im gesetz stehen und nichts
darüber hinaus und vor allem wir als
parlament haben die fäden in der hand
wir bestimmen ob eine epidemische lager
vorliegt und wir machen das jetzt nicht
für ein jahr sondern nur für drei monate
also kann keiner sagen dass das
parlament hier rechte auf die liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen das möchte ich
hier ausdrücklich auch an die adresse
der grünen sagen das war schon ein
bisschen starker tobak wie sie hier
gegen dieses gesetz geschaffen haben
ihre sachverständigen die sie genannt
haben sehen das anders diese politische
energie sollten sie vielleicht darauf
verwenden in grün regierten
baden-württemberg was dafür zu tun dass
die impfungen dort endlich besser laufen
liebe kollegin von
und wichtig ist auch ich will es ganz
klar sagen es ist ein zeichen der stärke
dass wir als parlament sagen wir nehmen
hinweise aus der rechtswissenschaft oder
auch von gerichten schöne grüße nach
lüneburg an die dortigen richter in
diesem zusammenhang diese hinweise
nehmen wir auf und das ist ein zeichen
der stärke und nicht der schwäche der
sagen nicht dass das gesetz
verfassungswidrig wäre auf keinen fall
es hat vor den gerichten bisher bestand
gehabt aber wenn es diese gewichtige
hinweise geben dann müssen wir auch zu
verbesserungen kommen liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen und das machen wir heute
mit diesem gesetz insbesondere ist es
auch wichtig vor dem was die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz gestern
abend beschlossen hat zugegeben diese
diskussion um stufen pläne
die können wir durchaus auch noch führen
ob solche regelungen nicht doch noch
platz im infektionsschutzgesetz finden
und ja es mag sein dass das recht
komplizierte regelungen sind aber eines
ist auch ganz klar bei all diesen
maßnahmen die gestern beschlossen wurden
zukünftig kann nicht nur der inzidenz
wert allein das maß sein ob eine
maßnahme angeordnet wird oder nicht
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen und das
wird ein beitrag dazu sein dass die
massnahmen gerichtsfest sind und das
stärkt das vertrauen und die akzeptanz
der bevölkerung was aus meiner sicht das
wichtigste gut ist in dieser pandemie
bekämpfung vielen dank
voraussichtlich letzte rednerin
sobald das mittel kult desinfiziert ist
ist die kollegin amy zoller cdu csu
sehr geehrter herr präsident liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen mit diesem
gesetz heute geben wir einen rahmen
wir geben den ländern einen rahmen die
zuständig sind in ganz erheblichem maße
das gibt unser grundgesetz her und
deswegen ist es wirklich nicht redlich
wenn einige kollegen hier so tun als
würden wir von seiten des bundestags
schlicht verfassungsrechtlich schwierige
entscheidungen treffen denn es ist nicht
der fall wir geben mit verschiedensten
maßnahmen den ländern den auftrag
entsprechend danach maßgaben vorzugeben
für die bekämpfung der pandemie
denn es verwundert mich manchmal schon
was denn jetzt gewollt ist sollen wir
jetzt regional antworten geben oder
sollen wir ganz starre vorgaben in einem
engen rahmen geben sollen wir
flexibilität ermöglichen oder sollen wir
eben alles bis ins letzte klein-klein
regeln und deswegen sage ich gerade auch
im hinblick dass ich weiß wie viel die
bürgermeister die oberbürgermeister die
landräte hier vor ort leisten in unserem
land das ist wirklich wichtig ist dieses
gesetz heute auf dem weg zu bringen und
dass wir eben gleichzeitig aber eben
auch im blick behalten dass wir
regionale antworten geben und dass wir
eben differenziert auch vorgeben gehen
können eben beispielsweise abhängig vom
instituts wert vor ort oder eben
abhängig auch von beispielsweise der
durchimpfung der menschen vor ort und
viele andreßen ja von den kollegen auch
schon angesprochen worden und wir sind
uns einig dahingehend dass wir mehr
impfen wollen wir wollen mehr testen
wir wollen mehr nachverfolgen wir wollen
auch mehr medikamentenentwicklung und
auch hier gibt dieses gesetz
entsprechend den rahmen und gibt
antworten denn wenn es um die im freien
folge geht dann ist es so dass wir uns
in diesem gesetz gar klar dazu bekannt
haben dass wir eben vorgeben wollen als
bundesgesetzgeber wo sich die ständige
im die stiko die impfkommission auch
daran halten muss und das ist im fall
beispielsweise um die ergebnisse geben
uns daher aufrecht dass es für senioren
für ältere über 80 dass es dort
entsprechend einen vorrang geben muss
und die zahlen belegen auch dass wir in
diesem bereich recht haben denn die wir
haben es gehört von unserem
bundesgesundheitsminister dass wir rund
fünf prozent der bevölkerung jetzt auch
schon geimpft haben und das im kern die
über sterblichkeit bei den über
80-jährigen komplett zurück gegangen ist
und deswegen es ist wichtig dass wir das
hier noch mal im gesetz festgelegt haben
und damit eben auch einen weiteren
rahmen geben
für mich ist es aber auch wichtig dass
wenn die kollegen von der afg eben sagen
dass ihr einen expertenrat in ihrem
antrag einsetzen wollen dann muss ich
eben schon fragen ja was denn jetzt ist
es jetzt die beendigung der epidemischen
lage haben wir jetzt keine pandemie oder
brauchen wir einen expertenrat und wir
als unions fraktion und auch zusammen
mit der spd haben hier ganz klar gesagt
wir wollen ein begleit gremium das jetzt
auch eingesetzt wird um entsprechend
experten zu hören und wir wollen auch
eine evaluation mit einem
interdisziplinären expertengremium und
dass wir dieses expertengremium
natürlich vor allem damit beauftragen
nach abschluss der pandemie entsprechend
ergebnisse zu liefern weil wir jetzt
mittendrin stecken ist es für mich nur
logisch und folgerichtig denn wir müssen
im nachgang abend vor allem bewerten
welche dinge müssen wo nachgesteuert
werden und deswegen
glaube ich dass es insgesamt ein gutes
gesetz ist und es ist eben nicht so wie
auch kollegen der grünen suggeriert
haben dass wir als parlament dort nicht
mitsprechen können sondern eben das
gegenteil ist der fall es ist
selbstverständlich möglich dass jede
verordnung auch per gesetz wieder
ausgehebelt werden kann von diesem
wohnhaus von diesem parlament und ich
bin sehr dankbar dass wir in dieses
gesetz auch dinge hineingeschrieben
haben beispielsweise die
entschädigungszahlen zahlungen für
eltern aber eben auch einen weiteren
schutzschirm für die pflegeheime und
noch viele andere maßnahmen die auch ein
ganz klares signal sind auch wir wollen
mehr normalität auch wir wollen
erreichen mit unseren maßnahmen dass wir
stück für stück zurück kommen aber wir
sind eben jetzt zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
noch in einer pandemie und wir wollen
gut darauf aufpassen dass sie uns nicht
entgleitet und in diesem sinne bitte ich
sie um unterstützung zu diesem gesetz
denn wir alle in diesem haus haben das
gemeinwohl im blick und danach richtet
sich unsere politik aus vielen dank
damit schließt sich die aussprache zu
tagesordnungspunkt 8 kommen wir jetzt
zur abstimmung über den von den
fraktionen der cdu/csu und spd
eingebrachten gesetzentwurf zur
fortgeltung der die epidemische lage von
nationaler tragweite betreffenden
regelungen der ausschuss für gesundheit
empfiehlt unter buchstabe a seiner
beschlussempfehlung auf der drucksache
27 291 den gesetzentwurf der fraktionen
der cdu/csu und spd auf der drucksache
226 5 44 in der ausschuss fassung
anzunehmen
er trägt ein änderungsantrag der
fraktion der fdp vor über den wir zuerst
abstimmen wer stimmt für den
änderungsantrag auf der drucksache 27 3
0 1 die fdp die afw bestimmt dagegen wer
enthält sich
dann ist der änderungsantrag mit den
stimmen der koalition bei enthaltung von
bündnis 90 die grünen und die linke
gegen die stimmen von afg und fdp
abgelehnt und damit bin ich diejenige
die den gesetzentwurf der fraktionen der
cdu/csu und spd auf der drucksache 26 5
44 45 in der ausschuss fassung zustimmen
wollen und das handzeichen
das sind die koalitionsfraktionen der
sind dagegen
er enthält sich dann ist der
gesetzentwurf in zweiter beratung mit
den stimmen der koalitionsfraktionen
gegen die stimmen der
oppositionsfraktionen angenommen
die beratung und abstimmung zur
schlussabstimmung liegen wir mehrere
erklärungen nach § 31 der
geschäftsordnung vor
die fraktion der afg hat namentliche
abstimmung verlangt die abstimmung
erfolgt in der westler wen ich weise
ausdrücklich darauf hin dass auch in
diesem teil des plenarsitzung tragen
einer medizinischen mund nasen bedeckung
besteht mund nasen bedingungen heißt
übrigens dass man die bedeckung nicht
unterhalb der nase und über der nase
trägt hat einige kollegen gesehen die
das heute morgen ein bisschen übersehen
haben und ich muss verstöße gegen diese
pflicht mit den mitteln des
parlamentarischen ordnungsrechts ahnten
ich bin die schriftführerinnen
schriftführer darauf zu achten
sie haben zur abgabe ihrer stimme nach
eröffnung der abstimmung 30 minuten zeit
gehen sie bitte nicht alle gleichzeitig
zur abstimmung stehen acht kommen zur
verfügung die schriftführung
schriftführer haben die vorgesetzten
vorgesehenen plätze eingenommen so dass
sich die namentliche schlussabstimmung
über den gesetzentwurf der
koalitionsfraktionen
eröffne die abstimmungs ordnet werden um
10 uhr 55 geschlossen
das bevorstehende ende der namentlichen
abstimmung wird rechtzeitig bekannt
gegeben das ergebnis der namentlichen
abstimmung über den gesetzentwurf wird
ihnen erst nach dem tagesordnungspunkt 9
mitgeteilt im anschluss daran setzen wir
die abstimmungen zu den weiteren
vorlagen zu tagesordnungspunkt 8 und
zusatzpunkt 3 fort so und jetzt soll die
heutige tag ist auch darum die beratung
einer beschlussempfehlung des
ausschusses für wahlprüfung immunität
und geschäftsordnung auf der drucksache
27 20